I see you shiver with anticipation yes
it's time for me once again as I say
it's time as if I had a regular schedule
of these it's an occasional series but I
am going to once again just gush about
one of my favorite movies and in this
case it's gonna be a movie I not only
loved but it was kind of really
important for my coming into my own I'm
gonna talk about the Rocky Horror
Picture Show so this movie holy crap I I
tried to think of how you would describe
this movie to someone who hasn't seen it
because at this point it's become it's
been around for so long and it's become
such a touchstone that you will see many
other things compared to it it's very
hard to compare it to anything else
though so if I were to try and explain
it someone who'd never seen it the Rocky
Horror Picture Show is a oversexed rock
musical version of an ultra-low budget
1950s sci-fi film like total b-grade
exploitive kind of thing that's what it
is but it's that made in the late 70s
done with with rock music you know
completely like is a oversexed very
gender bendy it's got all this stuff
going on but at its core that's what it
is it is the kind of story that would be
the second that would have been the
second feature on a on a late-night
double bill you know who that way back
in the day like before I was even born
that it would have been that kind of
thing except crazy and insane and with
legitimately good music so I I'm going
to assume having done that little
exercise I'm how do you describe to
someone who's never seen it that most
folks are
at least aware of what the Rocky Horror
Picture Show is even if they haven't
seen it so let's talk about what makes
this film awesome so first of all let's
just start with the music let's start
simple the tunes are catchy
they are sung with a lot of energy by
the cast they they come in at the right
points most of them actually move the
story forward it doesn't fall into the
trap of older musicals where they kind
of stopped the story dead to have a
musical number and then the story
resumes once the song is over the songs
are moving things forward which was
which was becoming the trend d'amour at
that point in time and it's oh they do
that but they're there they stand alone
and there are so many great songs that
are good to just listen to I'm
personally really fond of science
fiction double-feature
and the reprieves version of that at the
very end superheroes
well there's actually a proper reprise
as well but the that feeds into it I
sweet transvestite the time warp holy
cow it's just a jump to the left and you
know these these songs are legitimately
good songs they're fun songs they are
toe tapping songs and then there's the
cast you have in their youth at they're
just sort of right on the edge of
stardom you have Susan Sarandon you have
Tim Curry you have and even the people
you have meatloaf and even the people
who didn't become you know notable for
other things later on are still all
great in these parts Barry Bostwick is
terrific as Brad as this guy would just
he could not have a stick further up his
butt if he tried in the end to watch
what goes on with him over the course of
the film and then you've gotten some of
the other supporting players like
magenta and Columbia
now Campbell and oh god I've lost her
name all of a sudden I but this cast
though this cast is so so good but I
really have to take my hat off to two in
particular the first is Richard O'Brien
who plays riff raff but who also wrote
the original play that the movies based
on because if you didn't know this movie
just didn't form out of ether this was a
staged play first called the Rocky
Horror Show and so despite what you
might logically would think of oh my god
the studio must not have known what they
were doing this the studio which was Fox
licensed the rights to the play which is
just as raunchy as the movie and deals
with all the same stuff so they knew
exactly what they were getting and yet
somehow this got greenlit God the 70s
were kind of amazing you know right
before all the studios you know looked
at jaws and then Star Wars and decided
oh that's what we're gonna do forever
but you know there was there was a
really exciting time for a little while
of just crazy stuff being tried and this
ended up being one of them
but Richard O'Brien is riff raff he is a
truly magnetic presence on the screen
and I really wish he appeared in more
movies since this the few other things
I've seen him in he's usually one of the
best things in them but he has this he
has this creep factor for just a lack of
a better term I can't think of another
way to put it
he had comes across as a bit creepy but
not enough Oh get away from me in a I'm
kind of curious as to exactly what your
deal is kind of creepy which is tough to
pull off it's hard to be creepy and
magnetic at the same time but he is but
I've sort of sort of saved for the last
talking about Tim Curry as dr. Frank and
further and and talking about this I'll
get a little more personal on it
so at this point I think it's pretty
well known on this channel but just in
case I have a fluid sense of gender had
had for pretty much my whole life though
my sense of understanding of that is
it's been something that's evolved over
time but as much as my journey to I was
I was gonna say acceptance I've never
really been in a state of not accepting
myself but sort of coming into a state
of understanding the groundwork for that
was laid in my upbringing and the fact
that my mother was always very certain
to she embedded in me whatever I am she
would love me and she didn't she didn't
know about all this she didn't know for
a long time but I knew that no matter
what she would still love me and she of
all people introduced me to this movie I
was 13 when she let me see this movie
for the first time I don't know if she
just had an intuition that was something
that I kind of needed to see at that age
but I did I did need to see it and
before anyone gets like weird like oh
that's that's not appropriation watch it
come I can actually watch the thing it's
not as dirty as you remember it being
there's basically one nip slip one
f-bomb and then other than that it's
just the concepts are I was gonna say
abnormal let's go with a typical there's
a lot of sexually atypical stuff that
goes on be don't see any of it and a lot
of its handle very casually which again
is I think important to its impact
because I I actually I very genuinely
believe that this is an important movie
not in a you know teach it in film 101
you know Citizen Kane The Godfather kind
of way
it's important because of the impact it
has on a certain kind of audience member
who sees it for the first time
especially if they see it at a point in
their lives when they need it because
this movie better than any other movie
that I can think of embodies purely the
idea of let your freak flag fly whatever
you are that's fine don't worry that
you're weird we're all weird there is no
one in this film who is not weird even
the even the straight-laced characters
are revealed to be just as weird as
everybody else and it's beautiful and
it's celebrated as beautiful without
becoming pretentious because the the a
lot of the messages and a lot of the
themes up the core of this could have
been really heavy-handed really hammy
but it's just presented in this raucous
bizarre sci-fi way that kind of sneaks
it in on you and again if you're someone
who needs to get this it's it really can
make you feel that it's okay to be weird
and at 13 when I saw this movie I sure
as heck to know what the heck I was but
I knew I didn't fit the category of what
I understood to be normal I didn't know
what I was I didn't know what was going
on I didn't know where I'd end up I
still don't know where that dub that's
ongoing but I watched this movie over
and over and over again and I do believe
it honestly really helped me feel down
to my core there's nothing wrong with
being weird cuz everybody's weird
not everybody's weird in the same way
about everybody's weird it's okay you
okay and like I say for a movie that can
carry a message like that but not beat
you over the head with it that's quite
an accomplishment and it's lightning in
a bottle on a lot of ways like I there
are there are films that I hear compared
to this and I always think it's a
comparison that does no favours to
whatever film is being compared to this
and that night includes films I like but
it's also backfired so like I remember
people when I first came out comparing
Hedwig and the Angry Inch to this and I
couldn't finish Hedwig in the Angry Inch
I really need to go back and try that
again it's been over ten years since
I've tried to watch that but I couldn't
get through and I remember thinking no
that was a lousy comparison or I've seen
like repoed the Genetic Opera compared
to Rocky Horror Picture now I genuinely
love that movie but no there's nothing
else like this movie and like I said
other things can be compared to it you
can't really compare it to anything else
and going to a midnight screening of
this movie at 22 was the very first time
I ever went out in public in a dress and
I did it going to this movie and the
people who go to the midnight screenings
of this movie because I knew they
wouldn't judge me I knew I could go
there and be safe I didn't know where
else I could go because you know I could
think well I go to a gay bar like well
first first of all I know enough now to
know that you know crossdressers and
people with wobbly gender aren't
necessarily welcome and gave hers but
you know even at the times like well I'm
not I'm not gay I'm not attractive
demand so I knew I didn't belong there
like I I couldn't have told you any
where I belonged but I knew I could go
to a midnight screaming scream screaming
screening of the Rocky Horror Picture
Show and
[Music]
not feel like I was unwelcome and not
made to feel who weird because everybody
was weird who was there and we loved it
and if you've never been to a midnight
screening I would recommend it I don't
recommend it as your first ever viewing
experience of this film because I think
to get the proper sort of fullness of
that you need to know this movie pretty
much not necessarily front to back but
you need to have seen at least two or
three times maybe even at least once
recently before going to see a midnight
screening because you won't really be
watching the movie will you go to a
midnight screening there's two things
that go on the first is most of it night
screenings have a cast they have people
you know who are done up fully in the
costumes performing the movie like down
in front of the screen as it's happening
above them so you're getting the live
version as is playing up there and then
of course there's all the callbacks
because this movie and because it is so
weird
there are tons of bizarre pauses that
are perfect for the audience to shout
something out and most of it I can't
repeat because I try and keep this
channel clean the callbacks at a
midnight screen in the show are much
dirtier than the movie itself actually
is funnily enough but I think in many
ways it's the original Mystery Science
Theater 3000 fans would go and just
start shouting things I have the script
okay here's here's something I can tell
you to give you an example there are a
number of various points in the film
where characters get annoyed and just
like you know hit a table hit a
dashboard in the car you know whatever
and this is such this is the fine tuning
that they've got all these callbacks
down to audiences will say when they
know it's coming we'll go kill the
swerve Kells Murph Gilda Smurf hmm movie
to Smurfs nothing and that's on one of
the cleaner ones yeah you would have but
they
like that all over the place it is very
mst3k but it predates it by about 20
years and it's just such a unique
experience and I had the privilege last
year in 2017 at Boston Comicon to go and
to meet some of the cast now I don't do
the celebrity meet-and-greets at cons I
don't go to many cons in the first place
and I really don't do those because
there are money sink anybody's a
particularly big name you've got to pay
a whole bunch of extra money just to you
know get in there for like a minute and
even the folks who aren't that it's
still gonna cost you like 10 bucks for a
selfie 30 bucks to get something signed
you know it I don't I'm not that person
I don't I generally don't care but I I
went to meet Tim Curry specifically I
actually didn't even know that the there
were gonna be other cast members there
but now Campbell was there Patricia
Quinn finally remembered it who played
Columbia she was there Barry Bostwick
was there God that man's tall and Tim
Acharya was there and I got to meet them
and all four of them were wonderful and
appreciative and accepting and I went
looking like I wanted to look I wasn't
caused playing I wasn't going as a
character I was going as me and but but
in a way that you know would usually get
me a double take
in most please well I got some double
takes there but not not in the line to
meet cast for Rocky Horror just
elsewhere on the comment I don't know if
I'll ever do that kind of meet-and-greet
with a celebrity again but worth the
trip worth the cost
this movie it's important to me but I do
think it's it's important to more than
me I think it is a genuinely important
film and I think even if it doesn't
impact you the way it impacted me it's
still just fun it's loud and it's
raucous and it's insane and it's
oversexed and it's bizarre and it's
stupid at times but all in the sense of
fun let's go nuts and yeah I love this
movie so that's me rambling on for a
while about the Rocky Horror Picture
Show it really is one of my favorite
films so what are your thoughts about
this movie or anything else that I've
mentioned in the course of this
particular ramble whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do you know the stuff you don't
need me to tell you this stuff I do have
a patreon I'll mention that there's a
link down below for that plus all the
other usual gobbledygook so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]